in this video we are going to go over
the important AWS Services you should
learn for your Cloud interview as well
as the job instead of just going through
a list of services what we are going to
do like true Solutions Architects we are
I'm going to draw some real world
applications and Trends work backwards
from it and map AWS services to those
applications so that you understand what
AWS service is used at what part of the
application and it's easier to remember
easier to study and say in interview
let's get started okay so in the heart
of it all is application in any
application there is some business logic
and the business logic is running in
some sort of code so to run this
application you need a server This
Server is going to run on a data center
because recent study proved that 85% of
the workload are still on premises so
the first set of AWS Services you need
to know for interview is how to migrate
these servers to AWS so I'll call this
DC or data center so the first service
that you need to know is
ads or application Discovery service it
gathers the information of what servers
are running including databases and
we're going to come to that part in a
minute it and then the next service you
need to master is AWS mgn or application
migration service now after ads
discovers everything mgn can migrate on
premises server to AWS server which is
ec2 so this side is
AWS so this is your application code and
this is running in ec2 and this is also
called virtual machine now one thing
that is not available in data center but
available on the cloud is autoscaling as
more users start using your application
your virtual machine needs to scale so
you also have to study autoscaling group
but let's face it ec2 and Autos scaling
group is old news now if someone asks
you in an interview hey how are you
going to scale how are you going to run
you know E2 Autos scaling group your
friend know E2 Autos scaling group his
girlfriend know2 Autos scaling group his
crash know E2 Autos scaling group so you
need to set yourself apart so in
addition to studying ec2 you need to
know at least one of these kubernetes e
Cas elastic kubernetes service or if
kubernetes you do not like
serverless and for serverless compute
the service is Lambda so so learning ec2
and autoscaling group is not enough
anymore interviewers expect you to know
at least either kubernetes or seress if
you want to know more tips and tricks
like this that comes in the cloud
interview along with the study tips sign
up for my free Weekly Newsletter as a
welcome gift you get to download this
beautiful PDF with many different Cloud
question answer with the study notes
sign up for free at Cloud withth r com/
newsletter I'll give the link in the
description now back to the video going
back to the data center in addition to
running the code you also need to save
some information for example Amazon
needs to save what's in your shopping
cart what's the price of the product
what have you purchased Etc you need to
have database right so in your uh data
center so I'm going to extend this a
little bit you also need to have some
sort of database so I call this DB okay
and your application code is going to be
interacting with it this database is
running on premises you need to migrate
it so to migrate that you need to learn
this service called DMS or database
migration service thing to keep in mind
ads discovers both the servers and
database mgn just replicates the server
with the hard disk hard disk is the EBS
and then the database is replicated
through DMs so this database comes to
AWS you need to know at least one SQL
and one no SQL database for the SQL side
I recommend learning RDS for no SQL I
recommend learning Dynamo DB and Dynamo
DB also goes very well with serverless
in addition to just saving uh
information in a database there could be
some other kind of things that you need
to store YouTube you to store the
thumbnail the video amazon.com the
picture of the products Etc so database
is not good for storing those because
they they take a lot of space so for
that you need to use something like S3
bucket okay so that's the next AWS
service you need to master all right so
at this point our application is up and
running so now let's take a look at this
traffic so in real world applications no
one is allowed to access your virtual
machine or your server in that matter
directly right because this ec2 will
have a IP address you don't want to
expose that IP address also this ec2 can
die new ec2s come up they will be scaled
so you need a way to accept the traffic
and distribute the traffic okay so for
that I'm going to write traffic Gateway
and in this layer you need to learn
application load balancer
Network load balancer and API Gateway
what they are what's the differences
when to use what so I have a separate
video on that look that up if you want
so at this point we have created a very
very popular architecture which is a
microservice architecture you the user
sending traffic using application load
balancer application Lo balcer sending
traffic to ec2 or Lambda going to
database sending your reply back now
another kind of Architecture is becoming
very popular these days is event driven
architecture which brings me to the next
layer of AWS services so the transaction
still comes to traffic Gateway no change
there here you add additional layer we
will call it Eventing and for Eventing
you need to learn sqs or Amazon simple Q
service SNS simple notification service
and event bridge I also have a separate
video made for 2024 uh features
comparing all the differences all the
stuff I'll give the link up top so take
a look if interested there's also
another kind of architecture which is uh
popular in real world workflows so this
is like step by step sequential and
conditional workflow system so to do
that we use a AWS service called Step
function so I'm just going to put it
here so learn this service as well
because this service also unlock blocks
lot of the workloads so at this point we
understand different kinds of
applications and what AWS Services can
be used to create those but it's not
done though right because this is just
the bare minimum in real world you need
to monitor how your application is doing
which brings us to the next layer of AWS
services so there are two important
observability solution one is cloud
trail so cloud tril logs all the
infrastructure logs but then there is
also application logs application
performance metrics those are captured
in Cloud watch so let's say your
application logs is sent to cloudwatch
and then if there's a error you can also
create a alert from the cloudwatch and
notify Support fol cloudwatch also gets
the
information from this ec2 and get the
utilization Matrix that okay how much it
is used uh what is the CPU utilization
memory utilization disk utilization Etc
I'm just giving an example with the ec2
cloudwatch and cloud trail both is
integrated with all the layers this
traffic Gateway layer Eventing layer
server layer EK cc2 database everything
so you definitely need to uh learn those
now the next tier of services is what
makes a difference between average
candidate and a great candidate security
with this architecture Whoever has the
URL of this traffic Gateway can simply
call but that's not how real world works
is it with amazon.com you need to log in
YouTube you need to log in so you need
to learn at least these Security
Services first is Cognito which is used
for authentication and authorization
next you need to encrypt the data at
rest so this database of the hard disk
tied to the AC 2 and there is a reason I
did not put EBS EBS is the hard disk
associated with ec2 because that doesn't
come up much in the interview because
most of the data is stored on the
database okay so then you need to learn
KMS at least the fundamentals you don't
need to know the inner workings of KMS
and the next service that you need to
understand is IM am identity and access
management I'm just going to put a lock
of the services so that you know they
are Security Services
cuz they're important they're little
special so they get their little uh icon
now security is an important area so
these three are the bare minimum but if
you want to go to the next level then
you please also study these following
ones web application firewall or WAFF
Shield guard Duty and secrets manager
and they're easy like you don't need to
spend a lot of time on those but if you
can get understanding of those that will
be very very helpful so at this point
our application is running we are
monitoring we secured it what's the next
big thing that comes in people's mind
next cost right so you need to know the
AWS services that can help you track
cost and also optimize cost I'm just
going to put them here like dollar
dollar because cost you need to learn
compute Optimizer so I'm just going to
put the short hand and this compute
Optimizer actually integrates with Cloud
watch because remember Cloud watch has
the performance metrix the utilization
metrix compute Optimizer can use those
cloudwatch metrics and recommend you how
to save money and in addition you also
need to know spot instances reserved
instances and instance saving plan now
in real world all the stuff that we are
doing you are not going to go in the
console and then just create all this
stuff because then that's time consuming
you cannot really reproduce it in
another account easily it is error PR so
how do you solve that you solve that by
adopting infrastructure as code you need
to know at least one infrastructure as
code the aws's native infrastructure as
code is CFT or cloud formation so if you
do not know any infrastructure ascod you
can learn cloud formation but if you
already know one such as terraform then
this is optional you don't need to know
that no discussion goes without
mentioning jni right so how do you
integrate J so one way could be whatever
data you are getting J can analyze it
and tell you how to grow your business
etc etc so for jna you need to know at
least two AWS service one is bedrock you
should also run Amazon Q so Amazon Q is
getting more popular where Q you can
think of as like Amazon's chat GPT you
can ask a question about AWS services or
it is also helping you to troubleshoot
it will give you answer but now keep in
mind this is for General essay if you
are going for machine learning specific
positions then you also need to know sge
maker all right networking when you are
running your application in data center
this whole data center is yours right
like you want it you own all the IP
addresses Etc but when you are running
this in AWS AWS is also running in a
Data Center and multiple customers are
using that data center so you need to
have a chunk of IP address or a piece of
that data center that you can control we
call that VPC or virtual private Cloud
so you need to understand how do you
allocate IP addresses in a VPC what are
the subnet what is availability Zone
how can this applicational Advance or
NLB API Gateway tied to a specific VPC
subnets how can you provision EC Tools
in specific subnets how does traffic
comes in from internet to these EC tools
should we allow it how do you allow it
Etc so you need to study bpc Concepts as
well as AWS Global infrastructure if you
feel overwhelmed feel free to check out
my AWS for a beginners course I go over
over all these services along with their
use cases differences Etc maximum
discounted Link in the description all
right folks good luck on your AWS
Journey Keep learning and keep rocking